l'hôpital du monde arabe serait-il en
train de s'effondrer
surnommé ainsi pour la qualité de ses
services et ses médecins formés dans les
meilleures universités du monde
le secteur médical libanais traverse une
crise sans précédent
à l'image de seine qui a lieu en ce
moment même dans le pays
face au manque de moyens dans les
hôpitaux le personnel médical est de
plus en plus nombreux à fuir le liban
une situation que le chef du syndicat
des médecins n'hésitent pas à qualifier
de catastrophe
wahhab au total ceux qui sont partis
jusqu'à présent constituent 20% des
médecins la plupart des spécialistes
la bactérie est donc à fait à part année
ce serait catastrophique si cela
continue à ce rythme
l'inquiétant après l'autre mort avec la
dégringolade de la livre libanaise elle
les salaires des médecins converti en
dollars sont de plus en plus dérisoires
les banques
quant à elles retiennent en otage leurs
économies et impose des restrictions
drastiques
une situation que nour al jeunes boudent
ce médecin urgentiste à l'hôpital
américain de beyrouth ne tolère plus
nous avons commencé à voir que la
situation économique empire est de plus
en plus c'est très difficile vous voyez
que tout le monde autour de vous souffre
financièrement et vous voulez essayer
d'aider du mieux que vous pouvez vous
essayer de donner de faire le bien mais
donc j'ai senti qu'il n'y avait aucune
stabilité
je vis dans un environnement qui n'est
pas sur un environnement qu'elle compte
d'ailleurs quitté en partant pour les
états unis
avant elle elle ce sont près de 1000
médecins qui ont déjà quitté le pays
une fuite des talents qui n'arrange donc
rien aux difficultés que traverse
actuellement le liban